hello and welcome to another episode of
biographics I'm your interim host Carol
small and today we're talking about Gene
Roddenberry war hero policeman and
creator of Star Trek original article by
analdo teodrani
science fiction may not be our cup of
tea or coffee in this case it's very hot
but for the sake of the bit I'll take a
sip
ow but you may have heard of a certain
intellectual property called Star Trek
you may have never watched an episode
but its presence in popular culture is
so pervasive that you may have picked up
on that as a character with pointer ears
and Extras wearing red shirts that
always get shot if you're indeed a fan
of Star Trek you may also know this
Creator was credited as one of the most
Visionary authors of the entire genre
only hardcore trekkies which apparently
doesn't include me because I only watch
TNG
Picard's better than Kirk come at me in
the comments you may not be familiar
with the man's life story one that
involves life-threatening adventures and
serial seduction worthy of his lead
character Captain Kirk this is the long
and prosperous life of Gene Roddenberry
decorated War veteran civil aviation
hero police officer and creator of Star
Trek live long and prosper
and I'm hoping there are a lot of
Trekkie references in this video and let
us know in the comments how many of them
you spot and I'm going to try and look
out for them myself as well good luck
Eugene Wesley Roddenberry was born
August 19 1921 in El Paso Texas the
first child of Eugene Edward and
Caroline in 1923 the rottenberries moved
to California where Dad Eugene joined
the Los Angeles Police Department after
graduating from Franklin High School in
February 1939 Gene followed his final
example sign up for the police Science
Program Los Angeles City College or LACC
apparently he was quite dedicated to his
career path as he served as president of
the licc Police Club but during his
college year Gene found two new passions
exploration and flying well technically
three passions actually exploration
flying and a young attractive lady
called a lean hex
Rex trout what's that say no Rex wrote a
lean Rex wrote other three the most
consuming one was Ill of a flying Gene
even considered dropping police sciences
and rolling in Aeronautical Engineering
Instead This dilemma was solved by the
intervention of a greater force in the
sky it's one who's calling Gene could
not resist the US Army Air corps or uf's
AAC by early 1940 World War II been
raging in Europe and Asia in preparation
for a conflict the Air corps had began
launching the civilian pilot training
program to replenish their ranks this
was the perfect occasion for the young
Gene to learn to fly he first earned a
civilian pilot's license and then joined
the UC AAC in December 1941 strong after
the attack on Pearl Harbor after being
commissioned as a second lieutenant or
Lieutenant do Americans pronounce it
Lieutenant I've heard some people
pronounce it left-hand I'm gonna say
Lieutenant because that's how I've
always pronounced it Gene was
transferred to Kelly field in San
Antonio Texas there on June 20th 1942 he
married his college sweetheart a link
the two would go on to have two
daughters Barbara Anita and Dawn Allison
but for the time being they could not
spend much time together he was tying
for jeans boldly girl and serve in the
wall
by December 1942 second Lieutenant
Roddenberry had been assigned to the
394th Squadron flying a B-17 bomber in
the Pacific Theater Gene was the
co-pilot's crew Commander Lieutenant
Ripley would Christen their plane Los
Lobos among others the crew included
engineer staff sergeants katydus whom we
helped Gene called Scotty trekkies we'll
get that oh January 14 Gene Ripley and
the crew were sent on their first
bombing Mission Against the Japanese
Destroyer but the B-17 could not score a
single hit two days later Gene joined
another mission a nighttime raid against
an enemy base on borgenville island the
first part of the mission was a success
but then Gene's craft and the three
other b-17s were attacked by zero
fighter planes Jean's crew did not back
down from the fight and they downed at
least one Henry playing during the my
ensuing Skirmish throughout February Los
Lobos performed mainly sea search
missions largely uneventful except for
one occasion when a massive storm almost
caused Gene's B-17 to plunge into the
ocean but whether hampered the crew's
operations throughout late April and
early May 1943 when bombing raids over
borgenville resumed the night of May 13
June and his logos joined force of nine
bombers against Khalil and belay the
strike force attacked at night dropping
flares to illuminate their targets this
tactic also made them more visible to
enemy anti-aircraft fire but the b-17s
managed to return in one piece on May
20th and May 23rd Roddenberry and crew
struck out borgenville once again
distracting Japan defenses while the U.S
Navy mined the enemy Harbor on June 15th
the 394th Squadron was relocated to Fiji
for some well-earned rest their Gene
learned that you've been promoted to
Pilot was assigned his own B-17 promised
almost legally named the Croco crap
Roddenberry and his Croco crap flew
their first strike mission on July 8
1943 the attack was aborted at the last
moment though due to severe bad weather
three days later Roddenberry was
assigned another craft the Yankee Doodle
and this time I used to drop a load of
fragmentation Bombs over kahili on July
13th Gene conducted another successful
Mission over Healy as his B-17 destroyed
a Japanese anti-aircraft battery the
Yankee Doodle crew were then relocated
to Espiritu Santo Island for a period of
hour and routine sea search missions on
August 2nd at 6am Yankee Doodle was
gaining speed on Runway ready for
takeoff but there was a problem with the
engine and Gene realized immediately the
plane was not gaining of speed for a
takeoff he hit the brakes but the Yankee
Doodle continued to Roll Along the
airstrip the thick jungle at the end of
the strip approached menacingly Gene
ordered his co-part to unlock the tail
wheel a maneuver which may have
prevented disaster the lever control in
the wheel malformed shirt because of
course like right out of Star Trek here
all they could do was brace for impact
as Yankee Doodle slammed into a wall of
dense wines and tree stumps as the B-17
caught fire Gene team and most of the
crew made out a lie bought Sergeant
Kruger and Lieutenant wallum had already
died in the impact Lieutenant Gene
Roddenberry was exonerated from any
Fault by the official report on the
accident nonetheless he was badly shaken
by the experience by the end of August
he and other Veterans of the 394
Squadron transported back to San
Francisco where Gene was awarded a
distinguished flying cross
the assignment to the Pacific Gene had
found time to practice his budding
creative Talent Penning poem short
stories and even some song lyrics once
repatriated he was able to hone his
skills even further he was given a
non-combat role was in charge of
investigating airplane crashes for the
US AAC at the end of the war he was on
release charge with the rank of Captain
and entered civilian life working as a
commercial Ally pilot for Pan Am in the
break between flying passengers he
continued to write short stories and
poems and even enrolled in writing
classes at Columbia University then on
June 18 1947 he survived another
disastrous crash Gene was aboard Pan Am
flight 121 flying from Calcutta to New
York the plane made a stop at karish
Pakistan and left at 3 37 PM local time
ronenberry was released from co-piloting
for the next stretch of the journey he
took a seat amongst the passengers so
five hours after take off one of the
engines malfunctioned and stopped
working and the captain in charge Joseph
Hart assessed the situation decided to
push towards Istanbul with only three
engines cruising at 17 and a half
thousand feet the engine's got no
Heating and the craft lost attitude
attitude altitude it's like it's not the
90-0 drink more coffee the plane sold it
on for another three hours until it lost
a second engine the only hope for
survival was to crash into the Syrian
desert the hard impact ripped the left
wing off the fuselage the entire plane
turned about 180 degrees on the surface
of the desert and continued sliding for
some 400 feet flight 121 was now A
crippled flaming wreck Roddenberry
having suffered two broken ribs sprang
into action aided by two flight
attendants Jane Bray and Anthony Vault
he evacuated the shot passengers as the
Flames consuming the plane the heroic
trio calmed down trap passengers for
freeing them and ushering them to safety
some of the passengers clothing had
caught fire but Robin written on the
Flames using a nearby and quite handy
pillar running brain Vault and Brian
were able to rescue some 19 passengers
but a sudden change in the wind's
Direction engulfed the entire wreck
eight passengers and seven crew members
did not survive the disaster at dawn
Roddenberry asked two of the more
able-bodied passengers to cross the
Euphrates river and seek help from a
nearby Syrian military post a few hours
later Gene borged a small Syrian
military plane was flown back to the
base and was able to alert Pan Am
headquarters the company Flash the
rescue plane thus ending the ordeal for
the survivors Runway received a civil
Aeronautics accommodation for his relief
efforts during the crash we decided he
had enough of flying and understandably
so on May 15 1948 Gene understandably
resigned from Pan Am from now on he
would take to writing full time
thank you
oh or at least that was the intention
the runner is relocated to Hollywood
where Gina decided to try and make a
career writing screenplays for the new
medium of Television well the industry
was still pretty lightly underdeveloped
there was little career prospects for a
newbie writer Gene had to pay the bill
somehow so on January 1949 he joined the
Los Angeles Police Department climbing
to the rank of Sergeant his stint with
the LAPD would prove a valuable
foundation for his future career in
television first of all his policing
experience is made for valuable
inspiration when writing teleplays and
his superiors noticed his knack for the
typewriter asking him to write speeches
for no less an authority than the chief
of police moreover while on the four
steam became friends with Jack Webb
producer and lead actor for popular TV
crime series Dragnet a valuable
connection which later eases entry into
Tinseltown in 1953 producer Frederick W
ziv hired him as a technical advisor for
another drama Mr district attorney while
revising scripts Ron Berry came to the
conclusion that he could do a better job
than the current authors he was right so
in March 1954 he sold his first episode
script to zip his superiors gave him
permission to Moonlight as a freelance
writer and was pseudonym Robert Wesley
Hey Wesley Wesley I I get it
over the next three years Robert Wesley
wrote for shows such as the science
fiction theater and space Patrol
throughout the entire period Jean
pursued another passion of his extra
marital Affairs I did not see that one
coming apparently he is long-suffering
wife Eileen had to endure his frequent
flings with secretaries employed by the
LAPD Cop cheating on his wife
who would have thunk it professionally
his writing career was picking up
finally in 1956 he had collected enough
credits and commissions to leave the
police force and become a full-time
writer continuing to work as a
freelancer from 1956 to 1964. runnerby
wrote for popular show such as Dragnet
Dr Kildare and have gone will travel his
work on his latter series was
particularly praised he was named head
writer in his episode Helen of
aberdeenian won The Writers Guild award
raising in status ronery was able to
create and produce his own series The
Lieutenant set among the ranks of the US
Marine Corps while producing episodes of
this series Gene befriended actors
Michelle Nichols and Marshall barrows
you soon start an affair with both of
them and even tried to convince them to
enter into an open relationship Nicole
soon realized that Barrett was truly in
love with Jean and ended the affair
runbury's heart may have been torn
between Nichols and baron but it truly
belonged to science fiction he was dead
set on creating the ultimate Sci-Fi show
and soon he would achieve this gun
foreign
started pitching around his idea for a
serious setting idealized optimistic
23rd Century Center on a brave crew of
staffly as Laura's Star Trek he
attracted the interest of TV Legend
Lucille Ball and a production company
desolute Studio securing around 450 000
through the pilot episode the cage this
episode starred Jeffrey Hunter as USS
Enterprise as Captain Pike jeans
Paramore magell Barrow was cast as
Pike's second in command credited as
number one this pilot also featured
Leonard Nimoy as the iconic Mr spark
although in a far less prominent run
this episode was deemed to cerebral yet
promising and Gene set to develop a
treatment for the series as well as a
second pilot and his rewrites Pike
became Captain Kirk and Hunter was
replaced by William Shatner major
Barrett was recast as Nurse Christine
Chapel and Nimoy spark took her place a
second in command fighting interference
with network Ronald Ray also cast his
former lover and now friend Michelle
Nichols in the role of communications
officer Lieutenant uhara NBC eventually
broadcast the first episode of Star Trek
titled Man Trap on September 8 1966
sci-fi aficionados enthusiastically
welcomed the show though initially
garnered a overall mixed response as the
first season progressed however ratings
improved NBC were inundated by fan mail
on the network security weekly budget
for around 500 000 for the show's
production and the second and third
season rolled around ratings floundered
once more and but it was largely kept
alive thanks to Fan writing campaigns
well eventually NBC pulled the blog and
shut down the Original Series in
September 1969. so Star Trek the
Original Series lasted only three
seasons it was canceled after receiving
a mixed response non-levels of sci-fi
might wonder then why it became such a
big deal the fact is that Roddenberry as
a showrunner introduced some truly
Innovative Concepts not seen on prime
time TV before
um he depicted a post-gasty future in
which Humanity defeated poverty War as
well as racial and political differences
for example at the height of the Cold
War introduced the character of Ensign
checkoff a friendly Russia more
importantly he imposed a racially
diverse cast in a period where and the
Civil Rights Movement was still fighting
for desegregation when NBC execs
complained about the presence of an
African-American and Asian characters
Ronda replied and I quote if you don't
have blacks and whites working together
when our civilization reached the time
frame there won't be any people William
de zuhara was signed as a source of
inspiration for many African-American
girls to pursue careers in science and
Aeronautics her role was so important to
the cause of African Americans that when
Williams considered quitting the show
she was persuaded to stay by none other
than Martin Luther King Jr himself uhara
did not leave the Enterprise and she and
Captain Kirk even shared the first
interracial kiss ever seen on American
screens and this is where the pub quiz
aficionados I'm going to call you were
like so it wasn't the first interracial
kiss okay there's another show before
this that did have the another
interracial kiss but this is the first
well-known one and it's one of the most
important producer Alex kurtzman would
later comment positively on
roddenberry's approach to diversity
stating Gene ronbrew's greatest
contributions the conversation of
diversity in the future is that
diversity is never addressed in Star
Trek more in general Roddenberry
considered his show was a science
fiction allegory to deal with social
issues typical of the time the Specter
of War teenage rebellion racial
conflicts and the injustices in the
workplace week after week planet after
Planet Kirk uhara Spock Dr McCoy and
engineer Scotty tackle these challenges
with an optimistic approach of having
tolerance and rational non-violent
methods or unless William Shatner was
directly involved in which case it was
done well for the most part phase as
we're usually set to stunt
in parallel to the Sci-Fi drama
unfolding on the screen robinberry was
the protagonist who sound a little soap
opera behind the scenes while Star Trek
was in production Gene lived his
relationship with magell in the open as
they shed a flat near desilu Studios but
the urge of the show run away insatiable
neglected a string of lovers amongst the
Young and Beautiful actors working for
the network Andy Richardson an assistant
worker for NBC described how Roddenberry
insisted that young women in the show
fitted with skimpy outfits so he could
perv on them Richardson also reported
how Gene loved to overshare about
intimate quirky and depraved encounters
describing them as a freaky deeky dude
eventually this Freaky Deaky dude filed
for divorce from his first wife in 1968
before the process was finalized he
married majol in a Shinto ceremony held
in Tokyo on August 6 1969. the Cobra
would have a son Eugene Jr known as rod
in addition to negotiating his chaosic
love life Gene had to battle with his
own insecurities as a writer he had a
Clear Vision for Star Trek which he
starts to defend it against Studio
interference but in his quest for
Perfection he obsessively edited and
rewrote everything single script penned
by another author not in his own writing
escape the Draconian scrutiny the
problem according to biographer Joel
angle was that Roddenberry was great at
laying out the broad Strokes of the
series but when it came to writing
individual episodes he would say in part
he basically Couldn't Write well enough
to carry off a script never left
roddenberry's hands without becoming
worse hmm seeing some big similarities
now between Star Trek and its longtime
rival Star Wars here according to the
50-year mission by Edward cross and Mark
Altman the Star Trek franchise
flourished only when ronbury seeded
created control to other writers for
example shortly after the premiere of
the original series Gene took a
month-long vacation veteran TV author
Gene L took over production duties
laying out many of the most beloved
elements of the show such as the
friendship between Kirk and Spock and
the conflicts with the warrior-like
Klingons Kuhn also introduced the more
warmth and humor to a dialogue actor
William Shatner would later agree with
this analysis saying Jin Kuhn had more
to do with the infusion of life into
Star Trek than any other single person
unfortunately appears that Roddenberry
could all pre-petty resentments I'm
happy with Coon's growing influence he
opposes every move until left the
show out of sheer frustration he was
replaced by other less gifted co-shell
Runners which eventually led to a
decline in quality as of the third and
final season
Star Trek may have closed down but Gene
was not out of work by any means in 1971
he wrote and produced these exploitation
Thriller pre-made all in a row followed
by more sci-fi and horror pilots and TV
movies such as Genesis 2 request our
tapes and Specter roll number eight also
served in the writer's Guild executive
Council and was appointed governor of
the Academy of the television Arts and
Sciences in the late 1970s and early
1980s he garnered three honorary
doctorates from Emerson Union and class
and colleges all the while All Star Trek
was growing into what could only be
described as a cult phenomenon thanks to
syndication rallying thousands of
devotees known as trekkies or Trekkers
when NASA announced its first space
shuttle program the original name for
the craft was constant tuition will
track each floor of the White House with
their petition prompting the president
to rename the Shuttle Enterprise in
September 1976 which I think goes to
show how you know the the level of Pop
Culture saturation Star Trek had
achieved at this point throughout the
1970s Gene and magical displayed another
Talent marketing they extensively tore
Trekkie conventions advertising
novelizations of the original series and
selling merchandise produced by the
newly funded Company Lincoln Enterprises
ronbury had also realized that Star Trek
was a profitable intellectual property
and could not let go of it he attempted
to reset the show was an animated series
but again his limitations the writer
quickly became apparent after two
seasons of mixed reception the series
was quietly canceled in 1975 but in the
same year Gene started yet another extra
marital Affair this time with his
executive assistant Susan Sackett going
to Sackett the relationship continued
until his death in parallel the
hyperactive Gene entered into the talks
the director Philip Kaufman to produce
the Star Trek feature-length movie once
again Ron could not tolerate competing
creative Talent after endless fights
Kaufman abandoned the project the next
attempt in line was to produce another
live-action series Gene completed the
Bible for the show and concept for the
pilot episode in July 1977. the concept
was picked up by Paramount The Producers
love the pitch and decided to ditch the
plans for a series and turn the pilot
into a theatrical movie instead
Paramount tasks veteran scriptwriter
Howard Livingston to produce the first
draft which
you can probably guess was extensively
Rewritten by rombury later that year in
a later recollection by Livingstone
Gene's version was not well received by
the execs stating in part we all read it
and I was appalled and so was everybody
else we sat around looking at each other
and somebody said who's going to tell
him it's a piece after lengthy struggles
with Livingston Paramount and director
Robert Wise eventually Ron Bruce draft
was ditched and he was credited as a
producer despite mixed reviews the film
gross three times its production budget
securing the production of several more
movies five of which released during
roddenberry's lifetime he'll be credited
as an executive consultant for the first
three the continued success of the
franchise concert Paramount to announce
the production of a new TV show Star
Trek the Next Generation in October
1986. modern Brew's involvement was as
usual quite problematic hired as a
producer for the first season he brought
along his attorney and business manager
Leonard maislish the two actively
antagonize all the producers writers and
even the cast members according to the
already quoted ultimate gross the
terrible Duo used tactics such as verbal
abuse a shift to increasingly worse
Office Space as being dry parking spaces
and worse and so the adversaries were
fired or effectively forced to resign
tension behind the scenes was lifted
only when poor health limited Ron
Murray's involvement with the chef as
per a common Trope initial successors
were followed by excessors namely drugs
and alcohol abuse and this may have been
the cause for a series of Strokes which
Afflicted him in the early 1980s as Gene
failed into the background Paramount
hired showrunner Michael Piller who is
often credited for ensuring the success
of TNG Ron Bruce Health continued to
decline until September 1991 when his
conditions worse and due to a blood
clots on October 24th 1991 while his
doctors offices in Los Angeles the
legendary author suffered a
cardiopulmonary arrest who's immediately
taken to Santa Monica Medical Center but
it was too late Gene Roddenberry left
out Earth for good at the age of 70. his
remains were cremated and in April 1997
part of his ashes were launch into
Earth's orbit A fitting end for a man
who'd done so much to inspire science
fiction and indeed real-life space
exploration biographers and behind the
scenes accounts published in recent
years may have cast a shadow in one
Gene's private and professional conducts
which were undeniably problematic to say
the least what is also undeniable is
that Roddenberry never backed down from
a challenge be it risking his life to
save his passages in the desert while
jeopardizing his livelihood to defend
his vision and values to conclude in his
own words Armani that lives as it
happens to him means it head on and
licks it we turned it back on it and
starts to wither away
so thank you for watching this episode
of biographics as mentioned at the start
I've been your interim host Carl
Smallwood please check out the the
sister channels to buy graphics
Geographics and top tens no doubt link
below uh if you if you like me or you
want to see more of my work you can find
like Wiki weekends um Factory with Kyle
Smallwood or all the social media links
somewhere below I imagine and again
there's notice at the start this video
is based on original script by an Aldo
theodrani they provided links for us to
share they will also be below thank you
for watching let us know what your
favorite Star Trek moment is in the
comments leave a like subscribe all that
good stuff and as always have the day
you deserve
I guess I can end on like a little dumb
fun fact I think we covered this on my
channel fact theme but I'll give you a
cliff notes version at home if this gets
left in uh everyone was like the Vulcan
nerve pinch right now the PM like that
um Vulcans do it's like incapacitate a
human being or indeed any humanoid
Target in the original script for the
upsell that was introduced um it was
going to be just just a punch
like just Spock was straight up going to
just punch out Captain Kirk because it's
enough so where Kirk could be mind
controlled or something and uh Leonard
niemong showing a heroic amount of
restraint
um argued with producers against
punching William Shatner in the face and
said instead that well the Vulcans are
you know there are people of like pure
logic like violence seems like such a a
base emotion to like you know fall back
on the Vulcans wouldn't do that surely
that of them are dignified logical way
to incapacitate a humanoid Target and
they just basically bullshitted the idea
of the Vulcan nerve pinch and saying oh
yeah maybe they're so strong because the
Vulcans are super strong they can like
grip like a part of your body like big
select pressure point combat and
instantly incapacitate you that way and
I think in like Star Trek Canon they
explain that Vulcans have like their
psychic mind meld thing it's um related
to that
of just saying yeah when they the Vulcan
nerve pain doesn't actually hit a nerve
it's just what we understand it to me
it's like basically they just turn off
your brain which is terrifying but yeah
that's a little bonus fact about Star
Trek through there if you're like just
just yeah I'll I love the show so
it's always fun to share things about it
cheers